Bankers for example they make pennies  they make pennies and make pennies and  when a crisis happens they lose  everything they've made before and  effectively in 1982 I was riding on the  Black Swan I got so many hate letters  from Bankers in 1982 I showed why the  banks lost in one quarter more money  that they made in the history of banking  until then history Money Center banking  they repeated it in 1991 and of course  2007 you don't need more you know  examples so and every time that there's  another dimension it's not their money  they're losing it's your money anyone  here who files that piece of paper on  April 15th  is subsidizing them because when they  make the money it's theirs and when they  lose the money it's hours on April 15th  taxpayer sponsors it so we have here  what I call a transfer of anti-fragility  a banker is anti-fragile he has upside  no downside taxpayer has downside no  upside